[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit einer
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein können sie sich noch
erinnern an die zeiten als wir mal
schnell zum ausflug nach österreich
fahren konnten mal schnell zum einkaufen
nach holland zum urlaub in spanien
einfach so das ist gar nicht so lange
her mittlerweile liest man kompliziert
formulierte einreise regeln durch checkt
dreimal ob alle unterlagen korrekt sind
alles richtig angekreuzt und hochgeladen
das gilt auch für die absolute nummer
eins im tennis novak djokovic kam nach
melbourne um dort einen rekord zu
schaffen den 21 grand slam turniersieg
djokovic steht heute wieder auf dem
tennisplatz ein richter hat ihm das
ermöglicht nach tagen in einem abschiebe
hotel weil australiens grenzschützer
seine papiere nicht akzeptierten ob er
an den australian open teilnehmen kann
ist weiter offen dass er dort noch auf
sympathien des publikums treffe eher
unwahrscheinlich denn auch der
weltranglisten erste hat viele drängende
fragen zu beantworten in einem fall der
weit über den sport hinaus zum
weltumspannenden politikum wird ulrike
röttger hat mehr
sie jubeln und feiern auf den straßen
von melbourne als hätte ihr idol einen
großen sieg errungen
doch es ist ein richterspruch das urteil
der tennisspieler novak djokovic darf in
australien bleiben vorerst doch nicht
alle wollen friedlich feiern
alles schaut auf uns dieses urteil geht
uns alle an
es ist lächerlich niemand schaut mir auf
andere probleme nur noch auf einen
tennisspieler video
das die affäre schon längst die große
bühne des sports verlassen hat zeigt
auch eine improvisierte pressekonferenz
seiner familie kurz nach dem urteil in
seiner serbischen heimat
der richter war fantastisch er hat die
forschung berücksichtigt wie unser
anwaltsteam präsentiert hatte und auch
die der gegenseite und er hat die einzig
mögliche entscheidung getroffen nämlich
dass nowak frei kommt und nun seinen
beruf ausüben
und dann folgt eine szene die viel
aussagt über den fall und über national
heldentum der vater stimmt ein lied an
darin heißt es
ich bin stolz aus ganzem herzen ich
komme aus serbien ich werde nie weggeben
begonnen hat die causa djokovic bei
seiner einreise der 34 jährige gibt an
nicht geimpft zu sein beamte des
grenzschutzes setzen ihn daraufhin fest
eine ausnahmeregelung design
tennisverband mit dem bundesstaat
victoria erzielt hatte erkennen sie
nicht an
djokovic kommt in ein hotel in den
menschen sitzen die abgeschoben werden
unter den patriotischen serben entfacht
dies einen sturm der entrüstung der fall
wird zur staatsaffäre und zum politikum
ich habe mit novak telefoniert und ihm
gesagt dass unsere behörden alle
maßnahmen ergreifen um die belästigung
des besten tennisspielers der welt zu
stoppen
auch der australische premier spart
nicht mit deutlichen worten
regeln sind regeln es gibt keine
ausnahmen
djokovic ist einer der polarisiert nicht
nur beim thema impfen egozentrisch sei
er sagen die einen zielstrebig die
anderen sein großes ziel ist jetzt der
grand slam titel sein 21 da passt es
nicht in seinen plan bei dem turnier in
melbourne nicht dabei zu sein schlecht
für ihn und auch für serbien
als 2020 alle großen tennisturniere
abgesagt wurden organisiert er in
serbien eines mit publikum er ist einer
der nicht aufgeben will morgen wird nun
der australische einwanderungsminister
entscheiden ob das urteil von heute
kassiert wird ob djokovic spielen wird
abwarten
nach deutschland wo seit fast zwei
jahren elementare grundrechte
miteinander kollidieren und dann auch
zurückstecken müssen wie noch nie zuvor
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik das
wirkt schon fast wie alltag sollte es
aber nicht die frage wer wann wie
demonstrieren kann nun darf ist
elementar für eine demokratische
gesellschaft und sie stellt sich
zunehmend drängender auch heute abend
gehen an vielen orten wieder menschen
auf die straße es gibt gewaltbereite
extremisten die das harmlose wort
spaziergang bewusst wählen um es
aufzuladen bis es klingt wie eine
drohung es gibt aber auch viele die
damit nichts zu tun haben dazu
unterscheiden das ist genauso wichtig
wie schwierig das pony check berichtet
sie gehen in eine richtung ohne parolen
oder laute rufe aber bei weitem nicht
planen oder ziellos sie treffen sich zu
dem was sie als spaziergänge bezeichnen
in magdeburg etwa ca 2000 menschen waren
es allein hier am abend eine sponti
taktik die die 68er generation bereits
angewandt hatte um keine demonstrationen
anmelden zu müssen dennoch wollen sie
hier heute ihren unmut zeigen gegen die
krone maßnahmen gegen eine impfpflicht
gegen den start der versuch mit ihnen
ins gespräch zu kommen nicht immer
möglich
bin garantiert kein richter ich möchte
nur nicht diesen scheißdreck meine augen
haben ja um meine kinder kriegen das
auch nicht am abend treffen sie sich
auch in mannheim doch statt tausende wie
in den vergangenen wochen heute nur
einige dutzend wir sind für die vielfalt
meinungsvielfalt und diese
meinungsvielfalt wird nach unserer ein
nach unserem eindruck gewaltig
eingeschränkt denn wenn irgendjemand
irgendwo was gegen das impfen sagt dann
ist an impfgegner dennoch spontan ist
kaum einer hier in einem telegramm chat
wurde bereits am wochenende zur
versammlung in mannheim aufgerufen dort
hieß es jeder ist herzlich willkommen
und jeder einzelne von euch zählt bringt
familie freunde und bekannte mit erzählt
jedem davon denen ihr trefft damit es
sich rumsprechen kann
dann aber wurde kurzfristig der protest
an einen anderen ort verlegt genau diese
taktik macht es der polizei schwer
es ist tatsächlich ein katz und maus
spiel da wir eben immer wieder auf das
verhalten der versammlungsteilnehmer
reagieren müssen wie gesagt wir haben
keinen ansprechpartner mit denen wir
maßnahmen abstimmen können
die die sich überall in deutschland
treffen haben vielschichtige beweggründe
die einen mit sorgen die anderen mit
einem feindbild normale bürger aber auch
querdenker rechtsradikale darunter
insgesamt eine kleine gruppe im
vergleich zur großen mehrheit die aber
ihre aufmerksamkeit nutzt aus meiner
sicht darf man dabei dennoch nicht
unterschätzen dass diese kleine gruppe
auch gefährlich sein kann das zeigt sich
durch übergriffe ich halte es für
wichtig dass wir als gesellschaft
insgesamt darauf reagieren wie das
zeigen am abend fast 1000 menschen
ebenfalls in mannheim sie demonstrieren
und bilden zum vierten mal eine
menschenkette symbolisch um ihr rathaus
zu schützen wir hoffen natürlich alle
dass alle gesund sich diese pandemie
werden das ist endlich in dem schwert
wir haben alle keinen bock mehr aber
gewalt und konfrontationen und spaltung
jetzt das allerletzte was wir gebrauchen
können die menschenkette zum schutz mit
abstand und maske diese hier war
angemeldet und vor allem genehmigt
und noch mal kurz reden mit seiner
attacke aus unserer rechts redaktion
sarah guten abend wann wird aus einem
spaziergang eine demonstration schon
ganz schnell der mit einem spaziergang
eine demonstration wird braucht es zwei
menschen die mit einer politischen
botschaft losziehen die muss auch nicht
auf transparenten vor sich her getragen
werden oder auch salz gefüllt werden
sondern ein stiller protest ist auch ein
protest und das sind jetzt keine
speziellen krone regeln sondern es ist
immer geltendes versammlungsrecht und da
heißt es auch wenn man demonstrieren
will muss man das vorher anmelden 48
stunden vorher damit die
ordnungsbehörden sich darauf vorbereiten
kann man muss das nicht genehmigen
lassen nur anmelden mit geschaut werden
kann wie viele wo wann wie demonstrieren
können und genau das wollen die
sogenannten spaziergänger umgehen sie
tun so als würden sie überhaupt gar
nicht demonstrieren und sie tun so als
sei der protest spontan da ist es ganz
wichtig spontaner protest und
angemeldete aktion beide schützt das
grundgesetz aber bei den spaziergängen
handelt sich gerade um unangemeldete
demonstrationen und was macht ihr
zerstört wenn die demonstration nicht
angemeldet ist aber die menschen die
dabei mit laufend sagen das ist nur ein
spaziergang welche mittel hat der stadt
im grunde hat er drei große
möglichkeiten einmal präventiv schauen
weil die meisten sogenannten spaziergang
er sich soziale medien verabreden
schauen wer verabredet sich da und dann
entsprechend reagieren können wenn es
dir wenn dieser spaziergang statt findet
man kann dann auch schon wer das ganze
initiiert denn es gibt dann einen
versammlungsleiter auch einen faktischen
sagt man der ist zwar nicht offiziell
sagt ich leite diese versammlung aber
das ganze organisiert hat und dann auch
haftbar gemacht werden kann denn eine
unangemeldete demonstration zu
organisieren ist strafe bis zu einem
jahr gefängnis und ebenfalls präventiv
können die ordnungsbehörden reagieren
und das machen sie auch flächendeckend
in deutschland dass sie entweder über
sogenannte korona schutzverordnung zum
gesamtes bundesland regeln vorgeben oder
aber über allgemeinverfügungen in
bestimmten kreisen und städten regeln
vorgeben und wenn gegen diese und das
ist die dritte große maßnahme verstoßen
wird dann können sie bußgelder verhängen
oder aber wenn es gewaltausbrüche gibt
natürlich strafrechtliche maßnahmen die
menschen auch vor gericht stellen
bestrafen jetzt sagte sachsen eine
einschränkung die bisher galt nur zehn
menschen erlaubt die wird jetzt
erweitert die wird jetzt gelockert es
sind ab nächster woche ab 14 erst dann
wieder bis zu 200 menschen erlaubt sache
wir müssen aber noch mal ganz konkret
reden über das was da auf diesen
kundgebungen sag ich jetzt mal passiert
da gibt es auf der einen seite
rechtsextreme es gibt gewaltbereite die
große mehrheit sagt aber die polizei
etwa in berlin die dort dabei ist die
seit dem demokratischen spektrum
zuzuordnen die sei auch durchaus
ansprechbar für polizeibeamte wenn die
ihnen etwas sagen setzt bitte die maske
auf wie soll denn die polizei jetzt bei
dieser gemengelage im einzelfall immer
differenzieren genau das ist die große
herausforderung dass gar keine
rechtliche wir haben zwar nicht mit
einer rechtslücke zu tun sondern rein
faktisch er hat beispiel sachsen
vergangene woche waren 22.000 menschen
unterwegs 173 verschiedenen orten und an
die 2000 polizisten sollten das
sortieren und organisieren und da geht
der ganz große grundsatz die
ordnungsbehörde die polizei
grundsätzlich daran gehalten sich
zurückzuhalten erst mal gewähren lassen
und dann nur einzugreifen gegen
diejenigen einzugreifen die der gewalt
bereit sind und dafür braucht es
natürlich genügend polizisten genügend
ordnungskräfte um das ganze zu sortieren
damit man in versammlungen laufen lassen
kann aber auch eingreifen kann wenn sie
aus dem ruder laufen die attacke aus
unserer rechts redaktion herzlichen dank
für diese einordnung heute abend
so und jetzt bleiben wir hier in der
sendung noch beim thema corona für im
moment hier ist hanna und sie hat heute
die nachrichtenübersicht auf die dritte
corona impfung könnte bald die vierte
folgen für wen und wann genau darüber
haben heute die landes
gesundheitsministerinnen und minister
beraten allerdings noch ohne ergebnis
bisher sehen sie keine ausreichende
wissenschaftliche grundlage für eine
entscheidung anders bei den impfzentren
diese sollen nun bis jahresende bestehen
bleiben bislang war dies nur bis ende
april geplant
die diskussion um die zuverlässigkeit
von corona schnelltests geht weiter nach
der forderung nach einer liste mit tests
die die omikron variante gut erkennen
gibt es nun eine erste rückmeldung des
paul-ehrlich-instituts
demnach können 80 prozent der
überprüften schnelltests die omikron
variante sicher nachweisen laut dem
präsidenten des paul ehrlich instituts
gibt es in deutschland keine corona
schnelltests zu kaufen die unzuverlässig
sind voraussetzung sei allerdings dass
die viruslast bei den getesteten
personen hoch ist genau hier sehen
kritiker ein problem dem schnelltests
werden oft gemacht wenn noch keine
symptome vorhanden sind und die qualität
der tests ist sehr unterschiedlich
es war eine der längsten
regierungsbildungen in der geschichte
der niederlande ganze zehn monate hat es
gedauert doch nun steht sie die
regierung von ministerpräsident rutte in
den haag vereidigte könig willem
alexander die neuen ministerinnen und
minister wie zuvor regieren die
rechtsliberalen zusammen mit den
linksliberalen den christdemokraten und
der christen-union die koalition hat
keine mehrheit und ist auf die stimmen
der opposition angewiesen
in myanmar es die entmachtete de facto
regierungschef in sanssouci zu weiteren
vier jahren haft verurteilt worden
sotschi wird der illegale besitz von
funkgeräten und der verstoß gegen korona
auflagen vorgeworfen bereits im dezember
war die 76 jährige in anderen
anklagepunkten zu zwei jahren haft
verurteilt worden vor fast einem jahr
war die friedensnobelpreisträgerin bei
einem militärputsch
kürzt und festgenommen worden
menschenrechtler kritisieren die
prozesse als politisch motiviert
in kasachstan hat präsident tokarev die
gewaltsamen proteste als versuchten
staatsstreich verurteilt mittlerweile
sei die vollständige ordnung wieder
hergestellt
unterdessen erklärte russlands präsident
putin sein land werde keine revolutionen
in einem ehemaligen statt der
sowjetunion zu lassen bei einer
video-konferenz eines von russland
geführte militärbündnis sagte putin
zudem kasachstan sei das ziel von
internationalem terrorismus geworden
veränderungen die ganz beiläufig
daherkommen sind manchmal die wirklich
prägenden das können wir uns heute sehr
gut anschauen da sitzt in genf die vize
außenministerin der vereinigten staaten
zusammen mit einem vize aussenminister
russlands rein hierarchisch wäre da noch
luft nach oben aber sowohl im kreml als
auch im weißen haus werden sie den atem
anhalten denn auf der tagesordnung steht
nichts anderes als eine neue
sicherheitsarchitektur für europa so
zumindest will dass der russische
präsident wladimir putin hat
drohpotenzial aufgefahren an der grenze
zur ukraine in form von panzern und
soldaten und fordert
sicherheitsgarantien für sich
bemerkenswert auch werde heute in genf
gar nicht mit am tisch sitzt nämlich die
europäer selbst für begann berichtet
ein paar treppenstufen unter der
ukrainischen kommt statt hier wird
deutlich wie ernst sie die
kriegsgefangenen kiew nehmen ein
schutzraum für 350 menschen eine
telefonanlage
trinkwassertanks alles aus zeiten des
kalten krieges seit wochen bereitet
viktor kurz über die anlagen vor
im kriegsfall kann der bunker menschen
vor ort ellery beschuss auch vor bomben
schützen in friedenszeiten zb vor den
folgen eines chemie unfalls
es gebe keinen grund eine eskalation zu
fürchten sagt russlands
vizeaußenminister nach dem gespräch mit
seiner amerikanischen amtskollegin in
gipfel aber es sei besser einen schritt
auf moskau zu zugehen
würde es hassen in eine situation zu
kommen in der die nato und die usa einen
fehler machen und zum nachteil ihrer
eigenen sicherheit und der sicherheit
des gesamten europäischen kontinents
handeln
die stellvertretende außenministerin der
usa wiederum beharrt darauf sei an
russland zu deeskalieren
zum beispiel so wenn die firmen durch
den abzug der truppen die moskau in der
nähe der ukrainischen grenze versammelt
hat 100.000 soldaten sollen es sein dass
es sich um eine drohkulisse handelt
bestreitet moskau versucht stattdessen
sich selbst als opfer darzustellen
die büsche jetzt hören wir auch die
ukraine soll nato mitglied werden und
sie fordern garantien von mir aber sie
müssen uns garantien geben sie und zwar
sofort
die nato solle einen beitritt der
ukraine und anderer postsowjetischer
staaten ausschließen diese kernforderung
bekräftigt die russische delegation
heute die amerikanische lehnt das ab und
weist den nato-generalsekretär dabei an
ihrer seite
wir werden niemals von unserem grundsatz
abweichen wonach jedes land europas das
recht hat seinen eigenen weg zu gehen
selbst zu entscheiden in welchem
sicherheitsbündnis es sein möchte ein
nato-beitritt der ukraine ist derzeit
nicht realistisch in den schützengräben
des landes hoffen sie trotzdem auf mehr
unterstützung durch das westliche
militärbündnis
sieben jahre krieg gegen die von
russland unterstützten separatisten im
sonntaz haben die soldaten müde
ich will dass meine familie ein normales
leben führen kann ich will frieden ich
will dass wir nicht noch mehr tote
brüder in uniform beerdigen müssen
doch noch während die diplomaten in genf
über sicherheitsgarantien diskutieren
meldet die ukraine am nachmittag zwei
tote soldaten nach beschuss im
offen und direkt nannte die us vize
außenministerin die fast achtstündigen
gesprächen danach diplomaten spreche
halt die große frage bleibt was kommt da
jetzt auf uns zu und das ist die frage
in einer expertin für russische außen
und sicherheitspolitik sarah packung
forscht für die deutsche gesellschaft
für auswärtige politik und nahm
verpackung guten an tessiners was will
wladimir putin erreichen der einerseits
seiner armee auffährt und andererseits
von der nato eine sicherheitsgarantie
für sich fordert
russland hat sicherlich zwei ziele in
dieser ganzen situation dass es zum
einen eine west integration der ukraine
zu verhindern vor allen dingen sichtlich
der nato und auch eine militärische
kooperation unterhalb dieser
mitgliedschaft stelle das zweite ist
dass russland eigentlich im größeren
bild versucht die 1 1 eigene
verteidigungslinie weiter weg von der
eigenen grenze zu verschieben und das
ist ja auch ziel der forderungen in
russland hatte gefordert dass nicht nur
die nato nicht die ukraine aufnehmen
dass es keine militärische kooperation
gibt sondern auch dass es keine nato
truppen stationierung in den östlichen
mitgliedstaaten gibt aber das ist ja
quasi ein zurückdrehen der geschichte
oder
russland nimmt ja auch in seinem
verhandlungs aufschlag denen es ja im
dezember letzten jahres veröffentlicht
hat auch ganz klar bezug auf das jahr
1997 jahre vor dem großen nato
osterweiterung es geht letzten endes
darum diese art von pufferzonen zwischen
der nato und zwischen russland zu
errichten und die ukraine ist dafür
natürlich ein ganz zentraler bestandteil
jetzt redet russland auch von einer ganz
neuen sicherheitsarchitektur für europa
league da sogar entwürfe vor für neue
verträge ist das etwas was der westen
überhaupt akzeptieren kann in einer
sowohl die usa als auch die nato
insgesamt haben ja im vorhinein klar
gemacht dass sie kein russisches
vetorecht für irgendeine nato
osterweiterung
akzeptieren werden auch nicht
verhandlungsbereit sind hinsichtlich der
drucken stationierung in den östlichen
mitgliedstaaten aber sie zeigen sich
durchaus offen für verhandlungen
hinsichtlich von
grenzen von militärübungen aber auch von
raketensystem stationierungen die frage
ist jetzt eben ob das russland ausreicht
das hat er wie sie gesagt haben sehr
weitreichenden vor allem auch rechtlich
verbindlicher sicherheits garantien
gefordert sind denn die gespräche
alleine also dass da jetzt russland und
die usa zusammen sitzen bereits ein
erfolg für wladimir putin naja zumindest
ist es dahingehend ein erfolg dass man
natürlich die usa einerseits dazu
bringen sich mit russland zu
beschäftigen die usa fokussieren sich ja
zunehmend aus den asiatischen raum auch
auf china und damit eben auch die
sicherheit zu bedenken die forderung
russlands ernsten das heißt natürlich
noch nicht dass es am ende wirklich ein
ergebnis dieser verhandlungen geben wird
oder aber ob es überhaupt zu wirklich
weit reichenden und dann ja auch länger
dauernden verhandlungen kommen wird okay
was passiert wenn es dazu nicht kommen
wenn es ohne ergebnis ausgeht da reden
wir ganz am schluss noch drüber zunächst
noch mal die frage wer eigentlich was in
der hand hat auf der russischen seite
sehen wir den den truppenaufmarsch an
der grenze zur ukraine also durchaus
eine enorme militärische drohkulisse auf
der anderen seite hat der amerikanische
präsident den einsatz eigener soldaten
bereits ausgeschlossen was haben denn
die usa in einer hand also zum einen
wäre das natürlich eine erweiterte
militärische kooperation mit der ukraine
auch der weitere aufbau von
militärischen kräften weiter immer also
im nato ortsgebiet also den östlichen
mitgliedstaaten zum anderen sind es
natürlich auch und damit haben ja die
usa und auch die europäer und die
europäerin gedroht weitreichende
sanktionen vor allen dingen
beispielsweise im finanziellen sektor
aber auch hinsichtlich bestimmter
technologien
würden sie sagen wir sind jetzt bereits
an einem punkt an dem sich joe biden
quasi auf das spiel wenn man so will von
wladimir putin eingelassen hat na ja ein
stück weit hat man sich natürlich zu
verhandlungen drängen lassen angesichts
der russischen truppen stationierung an
der ukrainischen grenze die frage ist
natürlich aber auch was es hier für eine
alternative gebe ich glaube schon dass
es ein sinnvolles und auch wichtiges
politisches ziel ist eine militärische
eskalation zu verhindern und dafür sind
verhandlungen notwendig dieses wort
militärische eskalation hört sich
natürlich relativ
technisch an aber das heißt natürlich am
ende auch immer dass dabei menschen
leben
das ist menschenleben kosten wird auf
jeden fall was verpackung wenn die
gespräche scheitern was passiert dann
wir müssen durchaus damit rechnen bzw es
ist ein realistisches szenario dass
russland eine teil interventionen im
östlichen teil der ukraine starten wird
um nimmt genau diese militärische
kooperation zwischen der ukraine und der
nato zu verhindern dass es durchaus ein
realistisches szenario das gilt es eben
jetzt zu verhindern hat sich dank für
den blick hinter die kulissen so ein
bisschen sauer packung von der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
dankeschön bitteschön
das gespräch aber aus termingründen kurz
vor der sendung aufgezeichnet wie sollen
sich die europäer jetzt verhalten das
fragen wir nachher im heute-journal
update den cdu-außenpolitiker norbert
röttgen aber erstmal hier jetzt bei uns
hanna noch mal mit einer nachricht die
gerade im nordosten deutschlands große
sorgen macht die deutschen schiffbauer
sind nicht zuletzt wegen der korona
pandemie immer weiter unter druck
geraten nun haben die mv werften aus
mecklenburg vorpommern insolvenz
angemeldet weil er die halle an der
frankfurter börse was bedeutet das jetzt
für die 1.900 mitarbeiter das bedeutet
erstmal große verunsicherung aber auch
ungewissheit neben den mv werften hat
übrigens auch die bremerhavener lloyd
werft mit 300 mitarbeitern insolvenz
angemeldet beide gehören zum asiatischen
genthin konzern der durch corona in
schwierigkeiten geraten ist nun stehen
viele jobs und ein milliardenschweres
projekt auf der kippe das
kreuzfahrtschiff global dream das
größtes kreuzfahrtschiff der welt werden
sollte mit platz für bis zu 10.000
passagiere
doch schon vor jahren geriet das 1,5
milliarden euro teure schiff in
finanzielle schieflage bund und land
wollten mit bürgschaften und krediten
von über 600 millionen euro einspringen
noch am wochenende hatten die werft
mitarbeiter auf einen kompromiss gehofft
doch die verhandlungen mit dem chef von
werft eigentümer genthin führten zu
keiner einigung schon seit tagen warten
die 1900 mitarbeiter der mv werften auf
ihre ausstehenden löhne wie es mit ihnen
weitergeht unklar oder mit den acht 1500
arbeitsplätzen die bei zulieferern der
werft auf dem spiel stehen ungewiss auch
ob die global green trotz insolvenz
weiter gebaut wird die hoffnung bleibt
dass die werftindustrie an der
ostseeküste eine zukunft hat und dass
sich ein neuer investor findet der das
schiff zu ende gebaut vielen dank
valerie nach frankfurt
naturkatastrophen wie stürme und
hochwasser haben im vergangenen jahr
weltweit verheerende schäden verursacht
auf insgesamt 280 milliarden us dollar
werden diese beziffert versichert war
allerdings weniger als die hälfte das
berichtet der rückversicherer munich re
nun in seiner bilanz die gesamtschäden
der sturzfluten in teilen von
rheinland-pfalz und nordrhein-westfalen
im juli werden auf 33 milliarden euro
geschätzt
hollywoods wichtigsten filmpreis nach
den oscars vier golden globes sind
vergangene nacht verliehen worden dieses
mal allerdings ohne stars ohne roten
teppich und tv-übertragung mit je drei
preisen wurden die filme der power of
the dog und west side story
ausgezeichnet beste hauptdarstellerin
wurde nicole kidman bester
hauptdarsteller will smith grund für die
unspektakuläre veranstaltungen war neben
der omicron ausbreitung die anhaltende
kritik an organisation und
vergabekriterien der golden globes
prinzessin diana ist längst eine legende
dazu braucht es fast 25 jahre nach ihrem
tod keine filme mehr aber natürlich
liebt das publikum besonders den stoff
aus dem legenden sind und natürlich
haben sie längst gemerkt dass das hier
nicht nur die echte der jänner ist
sondern auch die im film oder in der
serie oscar verdächtig ist jetzt das was
kristen stewart leistet in der
hauptrolle eines dramas das konsequent
da je nach blickwinkel einnimmt und ihre
verlorenheit zeigen soll in der welt der
königlichen familie aus london berichtet
für uns diana zimmermann
weihnachten 1991 auf schloss sandringham
noch wichtiger war der film spencer
erzählt wie die drei feiertage in der
königlichen familie ausgesehen haben
könnten
sie kommen zu spät während die firma
bereits zusammen kommt hat der jänner
sich im eigenen sportwagen verfahren in
einem gasthof formuliert sie das motto
des films ich suche nach dem weg ich
habe wohl völlig die orientierung
verloren
ein star verloren in der welt und
besonders in ihrer familie
wenn überhaupt spricht sie im film mit
angestellten oder ihren kindern einmal
mit charles wie jeder weiß steht mehr
als nur ein billardtisch zwischen ihnen
bist du dir sicher dass du gehst nicht
zu spät wahr ist weil du von jemandem
aufgehalten wurde
nein aber
du wirst manchmal aufgabe von jemandem
und ich fände es gut wenn
du mir keine zahlen kaufst denn du hast
uns beiden die gleichen geschenkt
die prinzessin am rand des
zusammenbruchs
phänomenal gespielt von kristen stewart
[Musik]
der film ist ganz aus der imaginären
perspektive von dajana erzählt er ist
wie ein zu realer fiebertraum und wie
ich finde mutig und ziemlich cool
surreale szenen lässt sich der regisseur
einfallen doch für ein experiment klebt
der film dann doch oft an altbekannte
gefüttert wird das hat megan marke
wieder sehr aktuelle narrativ von den
bösen medien und deren tradition
erstarkten königlichen familie hier
existiert nur einer zeit die zukunft
gibt es nicht und vergangenheit und
gegenwart sind dasselbe
doch nicht nur die mode hat sich
geändert
geschichte wiederholt sich nicht es hat
sich doch vieles sehr verändert die
royals haben jetzt durchaus die
möglichkeit zu wählen sie dürfen fehler
machen sie haben die erlaubnis menschen
zu sein und das fängt ganz klar mit dana
spencer
anbieter des riester für extreme bei
der film ist ein muss für dana fans
bemitleidenswerter wurde die tragische
prinzessin selten gezeichnet vor allem
aber ist kristen stewart atemberaubend
zu recht wird sie in dieser rolle für
einen oscar gehandelt
[Musik]
eine weitere hauptrolle ist übrigens
deutsch besetzt schloss nordkirchen im
münsterland das nicht nur im film sehr
britisch sagt
das war unser erster tag als neues team
hier wir freuen uns sehr dass sie mit
dabei war da kann ich mich nur
anschließen und gegen 23 uhr 30 freut
sich dann dasein gökdemir auf sie in
unserem heute journal update in allen
ein angenehmer abend bis morgens
[Musik]
ein schon gute und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter die kopernikus klimadaten
sind veröffentlicht wurden und die
letzten sieben jahre waren die wärmsten
und das jahr 2021 reiht sich da ein und
zwar auf platz fünf die treibhausgase
haben neue höchststände erreicht
kohlendioxid und methan ja und wenn man
das jahr 2021 mit der vorindustriellen
zeit vergleicht so liegt die abweichung
bei 1,1 bis 1,2 grad wir schauen aufs
wetter und diese parameter beeinflussen
selbstverständlich auch das wetter und
im süden deutschlands da gibt es noch
kompaktere wirkung mit schnee das lässt
dann allmählich nach ganz im westen
klart es auf und ganz im osten auch
dazwischen gibt es kompakte worten und
dort wird es in der nacht am mildesten
bleiben mit plus 2 grad am kältesten im
osten mit minus 6 grad morgen
tagesverlauf gibt es vor allem im osten
viel sonnenschein und auch im westen
dazwischen auch dichte wolkenfelder die
entlang trifft nun die sonne durch
ausland verdecken temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte im ost minus zwei grad bis
plus sechs grad also im osten ist es
dauerfrost so ähnlich wie ist ganz im
süden der fall ist ja und die nächsten
tage gibt es immer wieder viel
sonnenschein am mittwoch - zwei bis
sechs grad und donnerstag sogar auch im
südwesten viel sonne am freitag minus
ein bis plus 9 grad damit ein schöner
abend